Nancy Pelosi is impeachment problem
getting a whole lot worse she reportedly
clashed with top Democrats during a
tense standoff last night and now Pelosi
is calling for a special party meeting
tomorrow to figure out how to deal with
it
despite the impeachment rift Pelosi is
saying there's nothing to worry about
keeps the president
but apparently Pelosi hasn't been
listening to people like Jerry Nadler
he's fuming over former White House
Counsel Don McGann skipping his
committees hearing and is ready to take
things much further first thing we're
going to do is hold you're gonna have to
hold McGann in contempt you're dealing
with a lawless president who was willing
to go to any lengths to prevent
testimony that might implicate him that
doesn't book 8 him
the recalcitrance of the president and
his lawless behavior is making it more
and more difficult to ignore all
alternatives including impeachment ok
Juan do you think impeachment is more of
a problem for Pelosi or for president
Trump you do Wow yeah I just you know to
me Pelosi sees first choice and I think
she's made this very clear to everybody
is not to impede right she wanted to
have a series of hearings if their facts
emerged that push people in that
direction fine but otherwise she wanted
to pursue a democratic agenda and she's
been doing it by the way just doesn't
get much attention but I think that was
her strategy Jesse but what we see is I
think Trump's not allowing the
investigations to go forward with his
blanket obstruction not only a people in
terms of Don began but documents the
judge yesterday just had to say the
financial records must be made to prove
available to the Congress of course
Trump immediately says that's a Obama
judge we're gonna appeal so that slow
walks at further I think he wants to be
impeached by the house because he then
will not be convicted by a Republican
majority in the Senate and then he will
say to his grievance loving supporters
oh you know they beat me up but I'm
still standing you know they sent Muller
after me I'm still standing now they
impeach me I still stick so he becomes
the victim for the conservatives who
love their grievance you're nodding your
head over here do you agree the Trump
wants to be impeached in the house I
think that it's like that Tom Sawyer
story where you trick the kid into
painting the fence by exaggerating its
therapeutic benefit is I go for it yeah
I do it dad because it's like this is
gonna be the greatest I think it's gonna
turn him into I don't think it's about
victimization it's about Clark Kent yes
are way too big it's it's folk hero
status when you go after somebody during
he's got a great economy going all this
good stuff is happening peace and
prosperity and your impeaching him it's
gonna turn him into Paul Bunyan but I
also had this this is my new theory
Trump will get reelected because this is
all theater literally he has become a
six theater AMC multiplex yes yes over
six movies playing at the same time you
show up at Trump theaters you got in one
theater tweet storm yeah and another one
you got North Korea executive action and
another one you got economy on fire and
another one you have celebs meltdown
three then on the other one you have the
other theory of collusion psychosis and
then you have rally fever and then you
have Family Affairs and so you have so
much to choose from right and the movies
aren't violent they're fun everybody's
having a good time it's per it's good
our core yeah I mean nobody he's gonna
be reelected because you're just making
more movies big box office Trump
tomorrow morning Pelosi is gonna get on
this phone call what do you think that's
gonna be like I think there's obviously
pressure and the other thing is it's
very interesting is that so far she's
been able to keep everybody pretty much
in line but now you see people who
disagree with her willing to go out and
do interviews there on the record
they're tweeting about it they're openly
in revolt so I think she had to have
this phone call of course every reporter
you know is gonna be on the phone call
so we'll also but in some way we'll find
out everything on the phone call I think
President Trump is already 98 percent
under impeachment and just making it
official will maybe change a little bit
but they're already doing all of the
things basically to impeach somebody all
the documents all the testimony all of
that request she has the support from
the majority of her Democrats but the
natives are restless because they're
saying wait she told us we have to win
the majority in order to hold president
Trump accountable but now she's saying
we can't hold president Trump
accountable because we have to keep the
majority and you can understand that
their grass roots are frustrated because
she doesn't want people in swing
districts Democrats having to take a
tough vote on
Pietschmann that's a really ugly vote on
an election year
yeah and that mixed messaging I feel
like it's wrapped up in with that revolt
and what do the constituents feel so
there are a ton of people there Democrat
sorry that ran in 2018 and that was on
well let's let the Muller report play
out the people who were crying about
impeachment worth the ones that were
running in battle states or whatever
right so there's that faction so now in
that revolt really revealing true colors
but also even people like for example
senator Warren who said oh well you know
upholding the Constitution like means
more than the party but if strategy when
strategy comes into play it is so
obvious because if it mattered to the
Democrats actually getting to the truth
or the bottom of everything then they
would be making a greater deal about
Muller testifying and what impeachment
does by the way is strengthen the power
to compel they are making a big deal
about Muller I mean they want my letter
testified Muller is the one that's
holding back and I think Trump is also
saying he doesn't want McGann to testify
this is about refusal to acknowledge
congressional calls they're going to
bend the Democrats are all going back to
the White House to talk about
infrastructure Oh already testified for
30 hours yeah why Muller yeah but not
know here we go